a few years ago Iraq's alambar Province
wasn't ruins the result of fighting an
attacks carried out by armed groups
under attack from isil Fighters but for
now the streets of Fallujah are deserted
today its main cities falluja and
aramadi are full of reconstruction
projects and new developments
has become a magnet for Investments we
facilitate the work of serious investors
to work in anbar Province since 2017
until 2022 we have managed to start
strategic projects in all parts of the
government especially with roads schools
and hospitals
[Music]
one of them is this hotel in arame
since the decline of isil it has risen
on the bank of the Euphrates river and
is nearly ready to welcome tourists
we need around 18 a month to finish
finalize our job here in the site only
the hindering by after the war of the in
the ambar the the the hinders while were
only the the corona Corona events once
the project will finish all all users
will will come here and many
gusts from outside from from out of Iraq
it's a change that many here have worked
for in the past visiting ambass main
cities would have been Unthinkable but
today improved socio-economic conditions
and decreased sectarian polarization
after the war against isil have made
such projects possible they are financed
by the provincial government or the
private sector Omar rawi as a property
developer who has invested millions of
dollars in residential compounds
when we first entered dramati after it
was freed from isil it was totally
destroyed like the aftermath of World
War II to rebuild the city within two
years is no easy job our investment here
is part of returning life to ourselves
and our people
what's missing is foreign investment
local authorities blame Federal
legislation and bureaucracy for
discouraging overseas investors from
entering the market but business owners
are hopeful
they say these busy markets are a sign
of a new beginning Iraq